incandescent or halogen stage lights
produce just one color the only way to
create more is to shine the light beam
through coloured plastic called gel
filters
however this LED stage light uses seven
different colored LEDs which can be
blended into a variety of different hues
this computer-guided machine places all
the components on the stage light
circuit board which contains 60 LEDs in
seven different base colors another
machine measures and cuts pieces of
insulated electrical wire then the
machine strips the insulation off the
ends and crimps on terminals workers
manually assemble ten wires and two
connectors into a control harness on the
factory floor they paint the stage
lights two-part cast aluminum housing
the paint process is electrostatic this
means the housing in the black powder
paint are laced with opposing electrical
charges back in the assembly area
workers install the stage lights
electronic components starting with the
LCD screen after covering the screen
with the protective plastic shield they
install the control panel this plastic
cover protects the LCD it also directs
outside air into the housing to the
lights cooling fan this block of
aluminum called the heatsink absorbs and
quickly dissipate some of that heat
they mount the LED array on top of this
two-fold cooling system then they
install the optically this plastic
component focuses the individual LEDs
they construct the stage lights mixing
tube lining its interior with adhesive
backed aluminum mirrors the mirrors
makes the seven LED colors into a single
color the assemblers now join the two
halves of the mixing tube adding a glass
lens on the front the lens focuses the
light produced by the 60 LEDs into a
single beam then they install the tube
over the optic next they mount the
control car to the side of the mixing
tube after installing the main power
supply
they plug a DMX cable into the control
card this stage light is now finished
and ready for a thorough quality control
check they plug it into a testing
machine which powers it up and verify
several functions the machine also
calibrates every color to ensure
consistency in every stage light they
manufacture then they run the stage
light at full power for three hours
non-stop to simulate strenuous operating
conditions
once the light passes these tests it's
ready for its stage debut